la viande
il est 7 heures du matin nous sommes le
lundi 4 février
retenez votre souffle le moment est
historique nous donnons le coup d'envoi
à une nouvelle radio de radio france
voici radio france or lui en 1985
françois mitterrand et président de la
république balavoine chanteuse isa et
france bleu orléans qui s'appelle à
l'époque radio france orléans et mais
pour la première fois
trente ans plus tard la fréquence n'a
pas changé sur le 100 points 9
on écoute bruno berthier l'une des
grandes voix de la radio locale présents
depuis 24 ans comment appelle-t-on les
rayons du soleil qui donne de la chaleur
ce sont les rayons je suis retombé sur
ma maquette que j'avais fait pour
postuler ici et je me suis dit waouh un
jeune présente ça aujourd'hui n'est pas
pris quoi clairement c'est devenu
beaucoup plus professionnelle c'était
après les années 80 le début d'une des
radios libres 1 mondiale des radios
libres et c'était de la radio soit la
valider on ne faisait comment le sentez
et puis progressivement il ya eu la
numérisation il y a eu la programmation
automatisés il ya eu la notion de réseau
si qui n'existait pas avant oui il y
avait 22 entités de radio locale de
radio france à l'époque on et 44
aujourd'hui et on est un vrai réseau
france bleu dans le loiret le
loir-et-cher 70 mille auditeurs son
fidèle à france bleu tous les jours
parmi eux gilles venu aujourd'hui pour
souhaiter un joyeux anniversaire à sa
radio préférée qu'il écoute depuis le
début j'avais entendu parler que france
bleu aller s'installer sur orléans
première radio orléanaise je dis bon bah
c'est impeccable j'avais télévores leur
dire écoutez moi je vous apporte mon
soutien je pense que ça va aller très
loin
votre vote à faire et gilles ne s'est
pas trompé trente ans plus tard france
bleu orléans fait partie du paysage
local
et si la façon de faire la radio a
changé le concept lui resté le même il y
avait effectivement une notion de
proximité de par la radio par elle-même
de par un groupe puisque la france est
un groupe qui n'existaient pas
et donc c'est je crois que c'est michèle
cotta à l'époque avait lancé
effectivement cette idée de faire des
radios qui soient intégrées dans le
paysage et qui soit sur les départements
sur les régions pour pour quelques-unes
donc c'était un petit peu le concept
départ 30 ans ça se fête alors pour
marquer son anniversaire france bleu
orléans va organiser tout au long de
l'année plusieurs événements